you and you and baby still haven't done
a record right
nah never is that is it babies it's so
crazy because me and baby ain't never
like really used to talk
i remember you saying that and how dope
was it that he just gave you that
co-signed a few weeks ago a lot of [ __ ]
it's real like it's kind of like [ __ ]
like because i never really saw him
talking about you either
but he just co-signed the [ __ ] out of
you i worked my like baby to tell you
though like [ __ ] i was on toys with him
you feel what i'm saying and like i work
my
ass off to get to like where i'm at
today so
[ __ ] it's like um it was a respect thing
like
like them i could respect what they
y'all [ __ ] doing and [ __ ] i just
appreciate that [ __ ] for real for
like oh for sure cuz like not it's not
like i waited for that
but like i for you to be like you know
you somebody from the state that gives
you some validation
most definitely i never and we always
talked about like from
um from the label like the south coast
side like we always talked about how
like
[ __ ] i never had no cold sides like a
lot of and you don't want to force
like all right look we're on the same
labels you want that [ __ ] to come
naturally
out like i never i've never been that
type [ __ ] like
i ain't never want to be no i don't like
features because i never wanted a record
to blow up
because of who's on it because who's on
it and then
i had i got a thousand and one songs
over here mm-hmm
um no i think that's dope i think now
though it's like only natural that's
gonna happen
oh yeah sure